The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right.
Today we go back to fun with
hardness proofs in games.
It's been a while since we've
done many games and puzzles.
So today we're
going to talk mostly
about this one paper, which
has a ton of results in it,
by Giovanni Viglietta.
"Gaming's a hard job, but
someone has to do it!"
What's particularly
cool about this paper
is it shows a bunch
of metatheorems,
which you can think of as
general techniques for proving
hardness.
And I'm going to talk
about essentially
two main metatheorems,
although there'll
be a few different versions--
one for NP-hardness
and one for PSPACE-hardness.
And this'll be our first
real PSPACE-hardness
proof other than lecture one.
And the proofs here
aren't very hard,
and the fun part is applying
them to various games.
And they apply to a
lot of different games.
So metatheorem we're using
here in a somewhat vague sense.
This won't be a formal
theorem, because it's
hard to state all
of the assumptions
you need about your game.
But it's sort of-- think of
it as a roughly true theorem.
We're not going to state all
the assumptions you need.
But the general setup
for metatheorem one
is that you have a player-- or
the paper calls it an avatar,
you know, a little
guy walking around.
You're traversing
a 2D environment.
So you're not allowed
to have crossovers.
From a given start location.
And given that setup, if you
have two features in your game,
one is called
location traversal,
and the other is called
single-use paths.
Then your game is NP-hard.
That's the metatheorem.
So location traversal
means that there
are some locations on the board
that you have to visit in order
to win the level.
So there's no target location.
Your goal is to visit
all of the locations.
Once you do that,
potentially you win.
Or maybe there is
also a target location
you have to get to at the end.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Does planar
mean you're on a plane,
or like a planar graph
kind of environment?
PROFESSOR: Either way.
You could be sort of in a grid.
You could be in a planar graph.
It's vague.
But the goal is
two-dimensional, so the point
is we don't need crossovers
for this reduction.
So location traversal, you have
to visit certain locations.
Single-use paths, you
can only use them once.
They're traversable, but
once you traverse them once,
they're no longer traversable.
So from this, you
can get NP-hardness.
Any guesses how?
What should I reduce from?
AUDIENCE: Hamiltonian.
PROFESSOR: Hamiltonicity, yup.
AUDIENCE: All paths
are single-use?
PROFESSOR: No.
Not all paths are single-use,
although it will work here.
The idea is that you mark
some paths as single-use,
others not.
So reduction from planar,
let's say, max degree three.
Hamiltonicity.
And so the idea is whenever I
have a vertex in my Hamiltonian
graph, I'm going to turn
that into a location that
must be traversed, because we
want to visit all the vertices.
So there you go.
That's where to put them.
And whenever I have an edge,
I'm going to convert that
into a single-use path.
And because I'm maximum degree
three and each of these edges
is single-use, once I
use one of the edges
and it disappears, and
then I use another edge,
and I get the treat
that was in that node,
and then I use another
edge and that disappears,
it's a really bad idea for
me to use the third edge,
because then I'm
trapped there forever.
So I would have had to have
already solved the puzzle.
I would have had to already
get all of the vertices
before going here.
So there was no reason
to traverse that edge.
Therefore, you're effectively
doing a Hamiltonian path
from the given start
position, which
we know how to reduce
from Hamiltonian cycle.
And because we can do planar
graphs, this is planar setup,
max degree three
is critical for not
being able to revisit a vertex.
OK?
We've seen a very similar
proof to this back
in the Hamiltonicity lecture,
but there, the assumption
was that there was a time
limit, plus collectibles,
plus location traversal.
This is another way to do
the same kind of proof.
And it makes it a little
easier to be convinced
that your proofs work perfectly,
because with time limits,
you're very sensitive to timing.
Every edge has to be
exactly the same length.
Here we're adding
single-use paths
instead of that to force
you to finish the level.
The claim is also it makes
the puzzles more fun.
So that's, of course,
up to interpretation.
But at the very least,
using this proof,
we can get a whole bunch more
games that we haven't seen.
So one of them is Boulder Dash.
How many people have played
Boulder Dash, let's say?
Yeah.
Only-- not very many.
I used to play this in
C64 days, Commodore 64.
But you are walking
around these boulders.
You can hold them up, but as
soon as you let go, they fall.
And if they fall
on you, you die.
So you don't want
that to happen.
And the goal is to collect
all the diamonds, roughly,
and then to get it
to a target location.
There's some weird physics
about how boulders fall.
But basically, here
are the two gadgets.
Location traversal, you
just put a diamond there,
and then you have to get it.
And then this is
a single-use path.
The idea is you can
come from either side,
push this out of the way.
The boulder is then in the way.
So if you then tried
to traverse it,
you can't turn around the
corner, so you get stuck.
OK.
So once you have
those two gadgets,
you get an NP-hardness proof.
So Boulder Dash is NP-hard.
Lode Runner.
How many people have
played Lode Runner?
A few more.
I used to play
these in, I think,
Apple IIe days or something.
Well, originally C64 again.
So you have this guy who walks
around, has to collect all
the parts again, these things.
And the fun thing about Lode
Runner is you can dig a hole,
and then the monsters fall in.
They'll drop their
diamond if they have one.
And they might be able
to climb back out.
Eventually, that
square will refill.
So it's a timed thing.
And so based on that
kind of physics,
we can build the
two gadgets again.
You put gold wherever you
want to make the thing.
And this is a
single-traversal gadget.
This is after it's
been traversed once.
You get stuck in the hole.
But if there's a monster there,
you can actually stand on it,
dig the hole, let the guy fall.
This will regenerate.
This guy's stuck, but now you
cannot traverse this thing.
There's no jumping in this game.
You can't jump over there.
You have to get to the
other side by falling.
And that's only possible in
the initial configuration.
So Lode Runner's NP-hard.
Questions?
Cool.
Also, Legend of Zelda II,
Adventures of Link is NP-hard.
On the one hand, we
have single-use paths
illustrated on the left.
And location traversal
we're going to do by keys.
If you get enough keys,
you can open enough doors.
At the end of the
puzzle, there's
going to be a whole
bunch of doors.
Let me get this one going again.
For single-traversal
paths, there
are actually these
bridges that disappear
after you traverse them.
So you can do some
amount of jumping,
but if you make it
really long, you
will be prevented from
re-traversing that path.
So we're going to put
a key at each vertex.
And then at some
finishing location,
we'll have end doors,
one for each vertex.
And that should do Zelda II.
OK.
So that is metatheorem one.
I want to tell you
about a slight variation
on this metatheorem, and then
another result based on it.
So metatheorem two is
same kind of setup.
So slightly different.
Yeah.
I'll keep a little
bit of suspense
about why we care about this.
Instead of single-use
paths, suppose
that you could
build tokens, which
are things you can pick up.
And for this
reduction, let's say
you can only pick up one at a
time, though it won't matter.
And toll roads, where you have
to pay with a token in order
to traverse the edge,
this essentially
can be used to simulate
a single-use path,
but it's a slightly different
perspective in that you can
visit an edge if
you-- well, what
we're going to imagine doing is
putting tokens at the vertices,
but just one at each vertex.
When you pick up that
token, you can then
traverse one of
the incident edges.
So again, every edge
will become a toll road.
And every vertex will
become a location traversal
point that has to be traversed.
And it will have one token.
And so you can use this
same kind of proof.
It's just a
different perspective
on the same kind of thing.
And we can use this to prove
that Pac-Man is NP-hard.
This is the motivation.
So again, you have to get
all the dots in Pac-Man.
So you, in particular,
have to get that one.
When you get that one, this
edge becomes traversable.
So this is a somewhat
generalized version of Tetris.
You have lots of houses for
the ghosts, lots of ghosts,
obviously.
The algorithms that the ghosts
follow doesn't matter too much.
The only constraint is that
ghosts change direction
if and only if
the state changes,
like you turn them into--
I forget the names of all
the modes-- but you turn
them into the blue mode
or they turn back, then
they will switch direction
in their tunnel.
And that is the only
setting in which
ghosts will reverse direction,
double-back on themselves.
They never
double-back otherwise.
And given that setup, if we
make these edges really long,
we can make sure that the ghosts
always stay within their edge,
because you're basically
alternating between switching
the state, turning the
directions of the ghosts,
traversing an edge, and then
doing it again and again,
so that the ghosts always
sort of go back and forth.
If you happen to capture
one, it doesn't really
change its location
much, because it just
goes back to the house.
But you obviously need one
of these in your possession.
You end up using
the token right away
to traverse one of
the incident edges,
so you can actually get across.
But it's long enough, so that
by the time you cross over,
the ghosts have reset.
So that is metatheorem
two applied to Pac-Man,
in case you were wondering.
This is, I think,
quite clever, to get
these things to work out.
OK.
NP-hardness, we're used to that.
The next metatheorems are
about PSPACE-hardness.
And before I get there,
I need to tell you
a little bit about some
basic PSPACE-hard problems.
Like, we have SAT and
Hamiltonicity for NP-hardness.
For PSPACE-hardness, there are
a couple of natural problems.
First, let me remind
you, because it
was lecture one that
I defined PSPACE,
these are all problems
solvable in polynomial space.
And so we're measuring
space instead of time.
This is contained
in exponential time,
because there are, at most,
exponentially many states
of a polynomial space machine.
And it contains NP.
In particular,
every NP problem can
be simulated on
a PSPACE computer
just by trying all possible
options for the guests,
but backtracking
and throwing away
the information from
the other guests' paths,
and just keeping one bit
of state, which is, did I
find a yes solution yet?
So you can turn any NP
machine into a PSPACE machine.
So it's somewhere in between.
The other fun fact
is that it equals
non-deterministic
polynomial space.
So non-deterministic
in the sense of NP.
If you add guessing to a PSPACE
machine, that doesn't help you.
You can always simulate it
with a deterministic machine,
at most, blowing up
the space by a square.
So if you had SSPACE before,
you have S squared space after.
Our polynomials are
closed under squaring.
So this is especially useful
for showing that a lot of games
are in PSPACE.
It's a lot easier,
usually, to give
a non-deterministic
polynomial space algorithm.
You have the freedom to
guess whenever you like, just
like with proving
containment in NP.
And if you prove
containment in NP space,
you are also proving
containment in PSPACE.
This is called Savage's theorem.
OK.
So that was just some
recall from lecture one.
And now let's talk
about some sort of base
problems,
PSPACE-complete problems
that we can reduce from.
I would say the most
obvious one is to simulate
a polynomial space algorithm.
You can relax it
slightly to say,
simulate a linear space
algorithm or a Turing machine,
if you prefer that.
Of course, you are
PSPACE-complete if you
can simulate all algorithms
that run in polynomial space.
And there are some proofs
that work that way.
It takes some simple
model of a computer,
like a Turing
machine, typically.
Like your reading and
writing cells on a tape.
And you're doing
whatever you can do
in that linear amount of space.
And just simulate those
transitions one at a time.
But it's usually pretty
tedious to do that.
I don't think we will
see any proofs directly
of simulating a Turing machine.
Usually simpler way to go
is a problem called Q SAT.
It's actually
usually called QBF,
and sometimes called TQBF,
and occasionally called Q SAT.
But I'm growing
on the name Q SAT,
because we can specify things.
It's consistent with
our naming terminology.
We can say Q 3SAT, and
we can say Q 1-in-3SAT,
and we can say planar Q SAT.
Whereas QBF, usually people
mean Q 3SAT, I guess.
But this is a little more
explicit what kind of SAT
we want.
So we're adding the letter
Q, which is Quantified.
So the general problem is,
given a fully quantified Boolean
formula, you want to
decide, is it true?
That's the T in TQBF,
if you prefer that term.
So for example, here is
a quantified formula.
It took me a little
thinking to come up
with one that is actually true
and in not a quite trivial way.
This is a 2SAT formula.
And so in particular,
you can read this
as x implies y, and y implies x.
And we're saying
for every x, there
is a y, such that
this is satisfied.
And that's true.
Namely, y equals x would
be the correct choice.
But it's not totally
obvious, given that formula,
that it's true.
And in general, given
such a formula-- probably
not with 2SAT in here,
but with 3SAT formula--
it's going to be
PSPACE-complete.
To contrast with SAT,
essentially, there
are a bunch of There
Exists at the beginning.
With Q SAT, you can have For
Alls in addition to Exists.
That's what we're changing.
And we can simplify
things a little bit.
We can assume a
prenex form, which
just means that all
the quantifiers are
in the beginning, and then
we have a 3SAT formula,
or whatever.
And we can assume that
the quantifiers alternate
between For All and There Exists
just by adding in extra dummies
if we happen to use a
bunch of For Alls in a row
or a bunch of There
Exists in a row.
But really, the hard case is
when you have lots of both,
and they are interwoven.
So it's not enough
to look at formulas
that have a bunch of For Alls
and then a bunch of Exists.
You have to think
about the case where
there are lots of
alternations between the two.
We'll talk more about that when
we get to two-player games,
because that relates
to two-player games.
But for now, we're going to
stick to one-player games.
And this is just something
we need to simulate
by our single player.
So now the question is, what
forms can this formula take?
Because we have lots of forms
of SAT that we know are hard.
And pretty much all of them
remain hard in this setting
as well, when you add
in the quantifiers.
And in fact, there is a
Schaefer-style dichotomy
theorem, like we
had with SAT and NP.
And basically,
this quantified SAT
is polynomial if and only if
the types of clauses you allow
are all Horn clauses, or
all dual-Horn clauses,
or all 2SAT clauses, or a system
of linear equalities mod 2 X
or and x nor
quality constraints.
Those could all
be solved before.
They can still be solved in
this setting in polynomial time,
even with alternating
quantifiers.
So that's cool.
However, it is no
longer polynomial time
if your clauses are satisfied
when you set the variables all
true or all false.
Because we have these For All
quantifiers now, being all true
is not the panacea
that it was before.
So that's one case.
And otherwise, you
are PSPACE-complete.
All other versions of SAT
are PSPACE-complete-- sorry,
of Q SAT.
So it's almost the same
as the Schaefer theorem,
but there's one
case that differs.
It's hard where
it wasn't before.
So that's cool for general,
from a formula perspective.
But we, of course,
typically care
about planar bipartite graphs
expressing those clauses
and their variables.
And good news is
everything works as before.
So planar Q SAT and planar
1-in-3 Q SAT are hard.
Planar not all equal.
Q SAT is also going to be
easy like it was before.
But planar Q SAT, we can use
the usual crossover gadget.
What that crossover
gadget does, it
forces some variables
to be the same,
but it also creates
new variables.
And those variables
need to be quantified.
All you need to do to
simulate our old proof
is put a whole bunch of
existential quantifiers
at the end of the
quantifier list.
So for every new
variable you create,
you put There Exists at the
end for those variables.
And we know those
variables are forced
to be equal to other copies of
variables that are given to us.
And so it stimulates the
old planar SAT proof,
but in a quantified setting.
And that was actually
done by Lichtenstein
in the original
planar SAT paper.
It also talked
about planar Q SAT.
And then once you have
this problem is hard,
the same reaction we had for
1-in-3 Q SAT also just works.
So with the same idea.
So there are some base problems.
Now we can do so reductions.
First we'll prove a theorem.
And then we'll apply
that metatheorem
to a bunch of different games.
One-player games.
So for next metatheorem, we're
going to have a similar setup.
We're traversing a
planar environment.
But this time we are
given a start location
and a destination.
Because we're no longer going
to have the location traversal
goal, we need to add
some kind of goal.
Otherwise, you've solved
the game by starting.
[LAUGHTER]
So it's a path traversal.
Get from A to B. And
what we're going to need
is a door plus a pressure plate.
So the idea is that there
is an obstacle, a door,
which is either open or closed.
And there's a
pressure plate, where
if you step on a pressure
plate marked open--
so you're walking
along here, you
step on this square,
that will open this door
and make it traversable.
As you go across it, you're
forced to open the door.
And there's going to be another
pressure plate marked closed,
which, as you traverse it,
you step on that plate,
it forces the door to close.
So in order to get to
the other side here,
usually this is in
some kind of tunnel.
So in order to get from
this side to this side,
you must close this door.
And we have more than one.
So there are many such doors.
I'll say A, B, C.
And this is going
to say Open A. This is
going to say Close B.
And we can furthermore
assume that there's exactly
one open and exactly
one close for each door.
OK?
So maybe I should
have written A here.
So this is the
complete story for A.
And there's a similar open and
close for B, an open and close
for C. And otherwise,
you can just walk around.
And your goal is to
get to destinations.
Sounds pretty simple.
And this is a very
powerful metatheorem.
This is PSPACE-complete.
This applies to a lot of games.
But before I get to what
games it applies to,
let's prove that this is indeed
PSPACE-complete by a reduction
from Q 3SAT.
We won't even need planar here.
We won't need planar,
because we can
open doors kind of remotely.
When I step on this button,
which could be far, far away,
I open this door.
So effectively, the connections
between variables and clauses
can be crossing.
There's no restriction
on that here.
So you're going to see a few
different proofs like this.
We'll see others
in future lectures.
But this is a typical prototype
for how to reduce from Q3SAT.
You have your start location,
you have your finish location.
Your goal is to
traverse this thing.
It's sort of like a circuit.
And then you have these blocks
which represent quantifiers.
We'll talk about
those in a moment.
In the end, you exit here.
And you have to satisfy
this formula in order
to get through.
If you get through, then you are
able to enter this quantifier
gadget.
And these are kind of
in a nested structure.
You can think of this
quantifier gadget
as calling this one by
traversing this path.
You're recursively calling
the rest of the formula.
And then this is sort
of the return value.
Yes, I did it.
I succeeded, I got a yes.
So for the existential
quantifier,
what this is essentially
doing is, say, OK, I
don't know what
x is going to be,
I'm going to let
the player decide
between two different paths.
Set x to true or set x to false.
So there'll be two
ways to go here.
And then you'll exit
along the same path.
But x will be set
one way or the other.
Recursively, you want
that formula to be true.
And if that happens,
then the player
will be able to come back here.
And if you successfully set the
rest of the formula to be true,
then it means the
overall formula is true,
because you just wanted to check
that there was at least one
setting for x that made it true.
And so this is just
a direct connection.
On the other hand, for
the universal quantifier,
this a little bit trickier.
And it's drawn at a
very high level here.
You need to check
both settings of y.
So what you're going
to end up doing
is if you enter
this gadget, you're
first going to set y to
true and exit out here.
And then recursively,
the rest better be true.
If it is, you come back here.
When you come back
here, you mark the fact
that you got one
setting correct.
Then you set y to false,
or the other setting.
And then you go out here again.
And if the formula
is again true,
you'd be able to come back.
And if you've accumulated
two correct answers internal
to this gadget, you know that
the overall formula is true,
with a universal
quantifier here.
And then you'll be able to
return out to the caller.
So that's sort of the
recursive algorithm
view of what's going on here.
Let's do that with
pressure plates.
So it looks a little bit messy,
but the idea is very simple.
It's to implement
exactly what I said.
First, these clause gadgets,
these are 3SAT clauses.
And what we're going to do
is just have three doors,
and you have to-- this is drawn
in the reverse order of what
it should be.
It's going right
to left usually,
but it also works in
the other direction.
If any of these doors is open,
you can get to the other side.
And in order to get
through all of them,
all the clauses
must be satisfied.
So that's the 3SAT part.
Really easy in this setting.
Where door open means that
the variable was set true.
In fact, we will have both
an xi and an xi bar door.
And so you use the
corresponding literals there.
Cool.
So now this is an existential
quantifier, an easier case
to think about.
So let's say we come in
from the left, as in here.
And that's coming into
this part of the gadget.
And we have to give
the player a choice.
They can either take the
top path or the bottom path.
Now, there's a worry that maybe
you go a little bit this way
and then double-back.
But that's not going
to be possible.
We need to argue that.
And negative means close,
and positive means open.
So if I come in here, the first
thing I do is close the A door.
That's going to prevent
me from later coming back
through this way.
I can only have one
door for each button.
But I want a literal to be
able to appear in many classes.
So in fact, I'm going to have
several copies of x here.
So this is the first
occurrence of x1 bar,
and the first occurrence
of x2 bar, and so on.
I want to open all
of those doors,
so I can use individual copies
of the variable up there.
And then I'm going to close all
of the positive versions of x.
This corresponds to
setting x to false.
And then at the very
end, I open the B door,
which lets me go through here.
The reason you can't
mess up this gadget
is if I went part way
and then doubled back,
I would immediately
close the B door,
which means I can't really
exit this way, which
means I'm going to have to
go all the way through here
and reset all of the variables.
And this is exactly
the complement of this.
And so exactly one of these
will be fully traversed.
The other one will be nullified.
And then that corresponds
to existential quantifier.
Question?
AUDIENCE: The doors
start in a closed state?
PROFESSOR: Let's say all the
doors start in a closed state.
Although, I don't think--
AUDIENCE: Can you close
things more than once?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Sorry.
One important thing is if
you click on Open when it's
already open, nothing happens.
If you click on Close
when it's already closed,
nothing happened.
So you can close multiple times.
It doesn't make it more closed.
It's just closed.
AUDIENCE: Stepping
on the Close and then
going back and opening
B seems to work?
PROFESSOR: So you could do some
of this and then double-back.
You're right.
B will open up again.
But by traversing all of these,
you undo all of the things
you did up there, because
these are complementary.
So you've fully traversed one
as the last thing you did.
That's going to be
the one that sticks.
Yeah.
So that's pretty nice.
And on the other hand, here
is a universal quantifier.
Not that much harder.
But this is
essentially-- there's
one door inside here
which is keeping track of,
am I going through this
for the second time?
So in this case,
there's no choice.
We just have to
try both settings.
The first thing we do
is set x to be true.
That's this setting.
And we also open
door-- or sorry,
we close door D. Oh, right.
Sorry.
Your other question is, do the
doors start open or closed?
I don't think it
matters, because we
have these close things in
the beginning, essentially,
everything gets closed
at the beginning.
So here we're going to close
D, which is our final exit.
That's where we want to get.
So that's going to be hard.
We have to get to
the open D spot.
Then we set x to our setting.
Then we open A. And now
we're allowed to go here.
You could try to go
this way, but it's just
going to close a couple doors.
So it doesn't really help you.
So we recursively call
the thing with x true.
If it comes back with the
thing being satisfied,
we can't go through here,
because D is closed.
So we're going to have
to go through here.
We open B. We
immediately go through B.
We immediately close B. So it's
like that's a one-way gadget.
Now we set x to false, the
opposite of this thing.
And we can't go backwards,
because B is closed.
Now we open D. So if we
can get through again,
we'll be able to exit.
We can't immediately turn back,
because again, B is closed.
We open C, visit C, close C.
So another one-way gadget.
And we also close A to
prevent other weird things
from happening.
So now we go through again.
If we get back with D open, then
we can return and we're happy.
And this gadget in the actual
construction, keep in mind,
what's happening
here is we are making
an exponential-length puzzle.
The length of the solution
is going to be exponential,
because you have to try
both settings of all
the universal quantifiers.
So any gadget is going to be
visited many, many, many times.
But each time, we're completely
resetting x, resetting x again,
and then returning.
So we'll revisit, will
reset x to true, and then
later to false, and so on.
But we are checking all the
possible assignments for here.
And we're letting the player
non-deterministically guess
assignment for the
existential quantifiers.
So that is pressure
plates in the abstract
PSPACE-completeness.
AUDIENCE: Sorry for
another question.
In our usual sense of
reduction, you usually
think of a polynomial
size thing that we make.
PROFESSOR: Good.
Yeah.
I didn't mention
it, but there are
different notions of reductions
for PSPACE-completeness.
But for the most
part, we will just
use the same notion of
reduction we did before,
which is the running
time of the reduction
should be polynomial time.
So here we're given a
formula which is expressed
in this kind of succinct form.
And we're producing
a level whose
size is polynomial in that.
Now, the actual
execution of the game,
the trace of what happens,
or the certificate that
is solvable, that has
exponential length.
But we're not talking
about MP here,
so we don't need
polynomial certificates.
But the reduction
itself is polynomial.
And again, of course, you need
to preserve the yes/no answer.
So that's our
notion of reduction.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Is there a way
to make this reduction work
where you just
have toggle plates
rather than-- so that they're
not marked with Open or Closed,
but just change the
state of the door?
PROFESSOR: Let's come
back to your question.
I have a proof that
does essentially that.
I was wondering the same thing,
but I'm not totally sure.
So let's come back to that and
try to figure out the answer.
So this applies to
many, many, many games.
Here is an example of an
RPG, one of the earliest--
Eye of the Beholder.
I think it's officially
DND-licensed.
It has a small number
of pressure plates.
Here you are.
You touch the pressure
plate, and this door opens.
Ta-da!
We don't know to what
extent these things exist,
but reasonable to
assume you have
this kind of infrastructure.
And then PSPACE-complete.
Even back in the early '90s.
A lot of first-person
shooters have pressure plates.
Doom doesn't have
literal pressure plates,
but it has triggers.
There's like walls that
if you walk through them,
something happens.
A block can appear, or
a monster can appear.
If you make a block appear, that
will essentially close a door.
If you make a block
disappear, which
is also possible on the
general script editor,
then you can do
all this in Doom.
Quake is the first
one I know that has
actual physical representations
of a pressure plate.
You touch this-- it's
a little hard to see,
but this drawbridge is opening.
And a little more far.
Adventure games.
It's hard to define the
generalization of an adventure
game, but one definition
is that there's
an older engine for
adventure games called SCUMM
for all the old Sierra games.
This, I think, stands
for Maniac Mansion.
That was the original
game they read it for.
But if you ever played Monkey
Island or Space Quest XII,
which that doesn't exist.
But there was Space
Quest IV where
they time-traveled to the future
and played Space Quest XII.
It's a very good
game, by the way.
A lot of these are actually
freely available now.
And anyway, it's an engine.
It has a very restricted
set of scripting languages.
And in particular, it
lets you do, effectively,
the style of pressure
plate things, where
if you talk to
someone, then they
make you go to a new
place, and they open up
some other traversal
options, or vice versa.
So you have to take this
a little bit liberally,
but you can
essentially implement
these kinds of things,
because you have rooms.
Here you don't even
need planarity,
and you can implement
pressure plates.
So that's cool.
A little more literally
pressure plates.
Prince of Persia, one of the
first platform PC video games,
I guess.
I don't know exactly
the right qualifiers.
This, I think, they
even did motion capture.
It's one of the first
instances of motion capture
for video games in the very
early days of graphics.
And you see in particular, this
was a pressure plate literally
that opens up that door.
So that's pretty cool.
One catch is that pressure
plates-- in this game,
you can jump, so maybe
you skip a pressure plate.
But if you put a pressure
plate on the top of a ledge
that you have to climb up, that
will force you to touch it.
So that's Prince of
Persia, PSPACE-complete.
All of these games pretty
much are in PSPACE,
because the state of the
game is some polynomial space
thing-- which things have been
pressed, or opened, or closed.
The total space of the
game is usually polynomial.
Each thing has some,
at most, linear number
of bits of states.
So the overall
thing is polynomial.
Or I should say
constant number of bits.
That doesn't matter.
I get to take a log.
And so you're just traversing
this giant state machine.
To store the current
state of the game
only requires polynomial space.
And at best, you're making
a non-deterministic choice
at each step, of whether I push
this button, or that button,
or wait.
As long as you
discretize time, you
get an easy NPSPACE
algorithm for pretty much all
single-player video games.
Not quite all, but all the
ones I've talked about here.
Cool.
So that is metatheorem three.
But this issue of having to
force someone to pressure plate
is a little bit restrictive.
And that you can
definitely get rid of.
And this is what Giovanni calls
buttons in metatheorem four.
If instead of doors
and pressure plates
you have doors and buttons,
you get PSPACE-completeness.
Now, this is a little
bit more restrictive
in that we're going to allow
a button to, let's say,
open or close three doors.
So pressing one button
has a bulk effect.
It affects three things at once.
This has since been
improved down to two.
But that hasn't
been published yet.
So I am going to cover the
published version, which
is this one, where
you manipulate
three doors for every
button that you press.
And here we're drawing
it with the buttons
on the sides of the walls.
There are many, of course,
physical manifestations
of this.
And the proof is a reduction
from pressure plates.
Question?
AUDIENCE: The buttons are
allowed to close one door
and open another?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So you can see that here.
One button will close
some doors, open others.
This is one gadget.
Here's the gadget
on the top-left,
and this is a sample
execution going left to right.
This simulates a pressure plate.
And in this case, you
can enter from the left
and go to the right,
or vice versa.
Although, in the proof, we
actually only need one of those
traversals.
So you could just stick with
the top half of the gadget.
And the white means open,
the black means closed here.
So the initial state is supposed
to be A is open, B is closed,
C is closed.
So you come in here.
If you want to
traverse, you have
to hit one of these buttons.
Let's say you hit the top one.
And we're going to
do this plus or minus
x, which is the actual thing
you wanted this pressure plate
to do-- open or close door x.
If this wasn't open for x,
there would be a plus x here.
But then also, we
will close the door
we just came through
and open the door
to go to the next spot.
Then you go to the next spot.
Let's say you press
the bottom button.
Because that opens C. And
you want to go forward.
So it's the only
one that opens C.
This one would have
closed C. And we also
closed D and opened B, which
gets us to the next stage.
And let's say we
press this button,
because this is the only
one that opens D. Then we
close C and open A.
The point of that
is to reset the gadget to
its original state of open,
closed, closed, open.
And then along the way, we
also activated x in the way
that we wanted it
to be activated.
So that was pretty easy.
Now we have buttons which
you can press or not.
But when you press them, it
activates three things at once.
And this also exists
in many video games.
Here were a few that I found.
We have the original
Tomb Raider,
and I think all the
Tomb Raiders probably
have some notion of switch,
which opens, in this case,
one door.
But you could imagine
generalizing to more doors.
We have Sonic the Hedgehog here.
When you press that
button, it opens that door.
You can use that to
simulate the same effect.
And this game,
Lost Vikings, which
I barely remember
playing, but I do
remember in particular that
the main character here
is called Erik the Swift.
[LAUGHTER]
And you see him pressing a
button which, in this case,
actually opens two doors.
So that's pretty compelling.
And in general, tons
of video-- I mean,
almost every video game
with some puzzle element
has buttons in it.
So now you know a ton of video
games that are PSPACE-complete.
Questions?
All right.
So the next metatheorem
is going to be
a specific kind
of implementation
of that same construction.
It's more of a physical
realization of a door.
It's a door that can
be opened or closed.
And it has various ways to
interact with that door.
If it's open, you can
traverse through it.
If you go through the
clause connection,
you are forced to close
the door, in which case
you can't traverse it.
If you go through
the open connection,
you can either just
go through, or you
can open the door if you want.
That doesn't really-- you
don't need this connection,
but a lot of gadgets
will end up doing that.
So this is just
one bit of state.
Door is open or closed.
And we can simulate
this kind of thing,
or simulate the previous type
of pressure plates if you have
a door, and an open
pressure plate,
and a closed pressure plate.
We're just sort of remapping
that into this gadget.
When you go through
the open traversal,
that's just visiting here.
And when you go through
the traverse connection,
that's going through the door.
And when you go through
the close connection,
that's visiting
that pressure plate.
And vice versa.
So you can take the
previous reduction,
translate it into this view.
Of course, you're going
to end up with crossings,
and it will be kind of ugly.
But you can do this.
So as long as you have
a crossover gadget,
doors-- this is called a
door gadget-- by themselves
are PSPACE-complete.
So we'll call this
metatheorem five.
I mean, this is very similar
to metatheorem three,
just like two and one
were very similar.
But just give it another name.
Doors plus crossover
are PSPACE-complete.
So this is sort of a
reinterpretation, if you will,
of the original Viglietta paper.
Viglietta's a co-author, but
this is the Nintendo Games
paper.
So this is-- you can think
of as a simplification
of that previous metatheorem
with pressure plates.
And then that has been
implemented in even more games
than you've seen so far.
So one of the first
ones we did was Legend
of Zelda-- A Link to the Past.
So a few things going on here.
But this is basically
the door gadget.
And then you're done.
There are lots of ways to do
crossovers in Zelda that's
not too hard.
We showed a hook-shot
version some time ago.
But anyway.
So there are these
notion of doors in Zelda.
These are currently
in the closed state.
And when you walk through
this in the open state,
you'd come out on
the other side.
And so in particular,
the to traversal
is going to be whether this
door is currently open.
Now, getting back
to the question,
in Zelda-- A Link to the
Past, you only have toggles.
If I press this button, all the
doors labeled one switch state.
But you can't jump and then
land on the thing again.
In this case, you
are falling down.
The drawing isn't clear.
This is the 2D drawing
of falling down a tunnel.
And then the only thing
you can do is walk down.
And then you hit a teleport,
and you immediately go here.
So this is one way to
get traversals to work
by preventing backtracking.
Sorry-- getting toggles to work
So the intent of
this gadget is there
are doors labeled one and two.
And it should always be
exactly one of those is closed.
Either the one is closed or the
two is closed, but not both.
And in Zelda, all the
games are initially closed.
So this is annoying.
So we have to build
this initialize gadget
through all of these doors,
where you come in here.
This is the end.
These are one-way teleporters.
You can't go up here.
So you have to go
here, toggle two.
Then go to this
teleporter, go here.
This is a block, so you
have to go over this way.
We're going to chain all
these gadgets together
through these initialize
paths, so that all of the doors
are initially in
the closed state,
with one closed and two open.
And then there's a
crystal-something
that you break.
And it flips.
All of these blue blocks
become these, and all of these
become blue blocks.
And that only happens once.
So now, basically, the
initialize paths are destroyed.
So now think of this
as being untraversable,
and this is traversable.
OK?
So now, if the doors open,
door number one is open,
then we can traverse it.
That's cool.
Let's look at the closed paths.
The closed path-- exactly one
of these is going to be open.
So if the door was
already closed,
that means two will be open.
We go down here.
We teleport to here.
And then again, because
two is the only thing open,
we go out through
the close exit.
On the other hand,
if the door was open
and we're trying to close it, we
have to be forced to close it.
And indeed, we'll
go through door one.
Can't go through door two.
We'll go down here.
We'll toggle door one.
Now door one is closed.
And so is two.
We'll teleport to here.
Remember this is blocked now?
Now we're forced to
switch two as well.
So we're effectively
simulating the effect
of doing two doors with
one choice of a thing.
First we flip one,
then we flip two.
Then we teleport here.
One was open.
We flipped everything.
Now two is open, and we
go out through the closed.
So in both cases, we
exit through close.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: How do you
ensure that the blocks only
get flipped once?
Because the crystals can be
hit as many times as you want,
right?
PROFESSOR: OK.
I had forgotten that detail.
Essentially, we want to
just put a one-way gadget.
So when you hit the
crystal-- I mean,
either you hit it or you
don't but if you hit it,
then we have a cliff that
you fall off of and visit
the rest of the game.
So you can't go back
and flip the crystal.
If you don't flip the
crystal, then the gadget
will break in other ways.
If you didn't flip
everything, you
won't be able to traverse again.
Yeah.
I should have that
drawn, but I don't.
OK.
So there's just one
crystal, and it's
hidden in between
the initializer
and the rest of the traversal.
OK.
So what haven't we done?
The open case.
So maybe we come
in the open door.
Well, we're not going
to have a choice.
Either it's already open.
Then we'll go through
here, teleport to here.
And we can go through
the one, and we're out.
Or it's closed, in
which case two is open.
Then we can't go here,
so we go down here.
We toggle one, we toggle two.
And then we go out here.
And now one is open.
So it's kind of cool.
When we're going
through open, we
know that we'll end up opened.
And so we'll go out the open.
When we go through
the closed traversal,
we know we will end up closed.
And so we will always
go out the closed exit.
And traverse is just
completely separate.
Cool?
So this is a door
in Link to the Past.
And so that's a good
example of toggles.
If you, again, have sufficient
crossovers and so on forced,
I think you could argue this is
more generally letting you deal
with toggles as long as you
can, right next to a toggle,
put a-- after traversing
it, you essentially
have-- say you have a one-way
gadget before and after it,
in a certain sense.
Here in Zelda, there's
only two levels.
So we can't make you
fall off another cliff.
But it's the same thing
with the teleporter.
We have a one-way right before
it, a one-way right after it.
You could only hit it once,
then you're essentially
doing toggles.
Cool.
Next one is Donkey Kong Country.
This is a recall of the
physics of Donkey Kong.
You can jump around and
kill enemies and stuff.
But the main goal is to get to
a destination other than points.
There are these bees which
kill you if you touch them.
There are ropes and
things you can climb.
And there are also barrels
that you can throw at things.
And there are three main Donkey
Kong Countries, 1, 2, and 3.
And they each add an
additional feature.
But none of them
share that feature.
So there are three different
PSPACE-hardness proofs, each
with an additional feature.
This is Donkey Kong Country 1.
Let me tell you the notation.
We have these bees,
which are stationary.
So those serve as
obstacles you can't touch.
Then there are these
bees highlighted in red.
They're not red bees.
That's different.
But they are moving,
according to this arrow.
So you imagine this whole
thing shifting over to here,
and then shifting all
the way over to here,
and back and forth.
And this is naturally occurring
in Donkey Kong Country.
You have bees which have
some horizontal path
that they traverse.
But we're going to
generalize a little bit
and allow the bees to
move different amounts.
This one only moves a
little bit back and forth--
I guess between here and here.
All right.
Then there's this additional
feature, which is this tire.
And the tire, if you
land on it, you basically
bounce back up very high.
And that's going to be annoying.
From the traversal
standpoint, we're
going to be in this barrel.
It's going to shoot us-- we're
forced to shoot straight down.
And if we hit this
thing, we are basically
stuck in this
connected component.
There's bees everywhere.
We can't get out.
OK?
On the other hand, if
the tire were up here,
then if we shoot down,
we can time it right,
wait for the bees to be
going to the right here.
And then we can run
down here and fall down,
and go through the traverse out.
Because of these bees, which are
going to go most over to here,
we can't go out through the
open setting from traverse.
But if we come from
the open setting,
because these bees are
going to go way over here,
we can run over and push the
tire up to this position.
So if you land on
it, you bounce.
But if you come from the side,
you can push the tire however
much you want.
So that will be pushing
it into the open state.
And these bees will
go right up to here.
And that's as far as we can
push it, right on that ledge.
Because you don't want it
to fall down the ledge,
which also happens in
Donkey Kong physics.
OK.
So that's open.
You don't have to
open, but you can.
Now, close.
You have to close the door.
And this corresponds
to coming through here.
If there was a tire here, if
we were in the open state,
we have to push the tire
off of the edge here.
And then it will roll
down to that position.
And if we time it right, the
bees will be right over here.
And then we can jump around.
You can climb the rope.
And if you're really fast,
you're climbing the rope.
And these bees are
really slow, rather.
Then you go over here.
This might not be to scale.
Maybe you want to
widen the section here,
so that you have more
time to climb the rope.
But that's just
constant factors.
Either you allow me
to slow down bees,
or you stretch this
diagram a little bit.
OK?
So that's close.
In order to get
from here to here,
you must push the
tire off the edge.
And then it will roll
to exactly there,
preventing you from traversal.
So that's a door.
Donkey Kong Country
1 is PSPACE-complete.
What about Donkey
Kong Country 2?
It has no tires.
But it has the balloon.
The balloon-- normally,
balloons go down,
as you might know, from gravity.
But if you have
these air currents,
the balloon will rise.
And when you're on
the balloon, you
can use it as sort of a ledge.
It may still go
down, but you can
control whether it falls to
the left or to the right,
according to whether
you press left
or right on the controller.
So this is actually
the closed state.
Again, there are these bees.
They're moving a little bit.
But if you time it right,
you can get down here.
But if you land on
the balloon, there's
no way to get
beyond this barrel.
And so you're stuck.
If the balloon is
out of the way,
it will end up being
here at position A.
Then when you shoot
from this barrel,
you end up in this barrel,
and you get to traverse out.
So that's good.
Again, these barrels
is a forced shot.
So you can't make any decision
at those types of barrels.
OK.
Good.
So the idea with the open
clause is that there's
a little bit of rope here.
So you would climb
this rope, jump.
When the bees are over to
the right a little bit,
they get over to here.
Then go on this balloon,
push it over to the left
here, and then jump back out,
and grab the rope, and leave.
And if you get the
balloon to here,
it will settle to this position,
so that you've successfully
opened the gadget even
though you couldn't get here
from there.
On the other hand,
the close is going
to force you to reset that.
So we get shot over this
way, shot down here.
Now, it could be we just
get shot, shot, shot,
and we're out.
But if there was a balloon
here, we will land on it.
In order to get to this
barrel or the next one,
we have to push
the balloon over.
Then we can go here or go here.
And we'll end up getting shot
to this position and out.
But because of
these air currents,
the balloon will go up to
here in Donkey Kong physics.
And so when you
do close, you are
forced to put the
balloon back here, which
is annoying for traversal.
So that's a door.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Is there any reason
you need the [INAUDIBLE]
at the top?
PROFESSOR: Why do
we need this exact?
I don't remember.
I was wondering that as well.
Yeah.
What it does do is force a
particular sort of timing
maybe, about whether it's
to the left or to the right.
But not sure.
I'll bet there's a reason.
But this figure was
drawn by Giovanni.
Cool.
What about Donkey
Kong Country 3?
Well, Donkey Kong Country 3
has neither balloons nor tires,
but it has tracking
barrels, with a T on it.
So tracking barrels,
if you land in one,
you can then slide
it left or right.
And when you leave it,
you always get shot up.
And even if you jump out
and then, say, go over here
and fall, the tracking
barrel tracks you.
So if you're coming
from traversal
and you get shot down here,
if the tracking barrel's out
of the way, then I traverse.
Then I'm forced to go down here
and leave via the close exit,
which is not what I want.
I want to leave according
to the traversal exit.
Now, this has some
leakage, but you
can show this leakage is OK.
You can go from traverse
in to close out.
But that won't end
up helping you,
because you were already close,
so you knew you could already
get to close out.
So this is the closed state when
the tracker barrel's over here.
This is the open state.
When we're in the open state,
we come through traverse.
We can jump out and leave here.
So that's good.
On the other hand, if we
come via the open position,
we can go get shot down here.
And if the barrel
was there, we're
going to have to
move it over here.
I guess we don't have to.
We could leave it there.
But we are able to
bring the barrel over
here and leave through open.
And now we're in the open state.
That's good.
On the other hand, if
we come from close,
if it's currently open, we
will be shot into the barrel.
And then to get
over here, we have
to bring the barrel
over here, putting it
into the close state.
Now, this is the relevant part,
where the tracking hurts you.
You go in here.
You'd like to just jump
out and get out here,
but because it's a tracking
barrel, if you jump out here,
the barrel will come over anyway
even though you don't go back
into it.
So if you leave
through the close exit,
you have to bring the
barrel over to the right.
So that forces the clothes,
preventing traversal.
That's Donkey Kong Country 3.
But there's one Nintendo
game that rules them all,
and that is Super Mario Bros.
And for the first
time, we are announcing
a PSPACE-completeness
result for Super Mario Bros.
So the Nintendo paper
and another paper
by Giovanni, which I
will talk about next,
was prevented at Fun with
Algorithms earlier this summer.
Two people were there.
And then we started
talking, oh, we
should really prove Mario Bros.
is also a PSPACE-complete.
So this is our
current reduction.
You may recall another
crossover gadget
that involved invincibility
stars, or mushrooms,
or something.
Those are consumables.
We can't afford consumables
in a PSPACE reduction,
because we have to visit
the same thing many times.
But using Mario physics,
we designed this crossover.
You're going to be small Mario
throughout this reduction.
If you come up here and you
run, you will fall here.
And if you come over there,
you run, you'll fall here.
But you can't jump
around and land here.
You'll end up down here.
And that's larger than
your jump distance.
OK?
So as long as you can't
glitch through walls,
this is a valid crossover
and it's reusable.
It's a one-way crossover.
You can only go from up to down.
OK.
Now the door.
The door's a little bit weird.
But it has actually been built
by modifying the Super Mario
Bros.
ROM, so it does exist in the
physics of the real Mario.
This doesn't have to be
length, but this is a fire bar,
which is normally rotating.
But if it has size one,
then it doesn't really
do much rotating.
So these are things you're
not allowed to touch.
The version we
implemented has fire bars.
Those do exist in the ROM.
But even if you have fire
bars that are much bigger,
you can still do all the things
you need to do in this gadget.
It's just a lot harder
to do correctly.
I was trying it earlier today.
[LAUGHTER]
And then we have this guy.
I forget what they're
called, but they're dropped
by the cloud thing in the sky.
You can also create them at
the beginning of the level
even though that doesn't
appear in the true levels.
You can make a new level that
has these guys initially.
It'll just be the case that
there's also a cloud floating
around at the top.
But if you shield
from that, you're OK.
So there's one of these
guys, and he can basically
be walking back and
forth here or over here.
And you can flip
that by if you hit
this block with
the right timing,
this guy will end up bouncing
and walking over here.
And practice.
You have to hit it a few times.
Sometimes he'll walk back over.
But if you get the direction
that he's facing right,
he'll jump up and
then keep going.
And then he'll be over
in the other side.
OK.
But you can't just
reach everything here.
If you are on the open side,
you can hit him if you want
and put him over there.
That's going to be
the open setting.
The traversal requires
you to go through this way
without the ability
to hit this thing.
And so if the spiny guy
is over on the left,
you will die, guaranteed.
We checked.
And otherwise, you
jump-- if he's not there,
if it's on the right side,
then you can traverse.
So this is the open
state that's drawn.
So this is the tricky part.
We need something that's
untraversable by the player
but traversable by the monster.
And this could be a fire
bar that's rotating.
If you time it right, you
could still rush by it.
And of course, close.
Close, we need to force this
guy to be on the other side.
And so we do the same thing
that we did on the left
to go through to close.
Just like on the left, this guy
has to be on the other side.
So first, you can knock
him over to the other side.
And then you can go back
and jump through there.
So Super Mario Bros.
is PSPACE-complete.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What was the advantage
of the rotating fire bar?
PROFESSOR: Oh, it's more
naturally occurring.
In real Mario, there
are rotating fire bars.
There's never this single
fire just floating in midair.
Fire bars can float in midair.
In all the levels that
exist in Super Mario Bros.,
fire bars are a fixed length.
We have six fire
things or whatever.
But in the ROM, it
has support for making
fire bars of arbitrary
length or up to some size.
So you can make this in the ROM,
or you can have it rotating.
And then it's a more
intense experience.
AUDIENCE: Why are there
fire bars [INAUDIBLE]
that they're hitting?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
That's dealing with glitches.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What is the shell
guy dropped by the cloud thing?
Or I don't know the game.
PROFESSOR: Oh, in the game,
the cloud is up there.
And every few seconds,
he throws one,
and it falls in some
kind of random spot.
And then he traverses left and
right like a regular turtle.
But in this, we're assuming
that you can have him initially
appear there.
So he's not thrown by the cloud.
There would also be a
cloud throwing spiny guys.
We're assuming that
this guy can just
be there from the beginning.
AUDIENCE: So it
drops more than one?
PROFESSOR: Oh, yeah.
It drops one, and then drops
another, and drops another.
I think it's unlimited.
I mean, there might
be a practical limit
given by the memory of an
NES, which is pretty small.
But I think it limits to like
eight creatures on screen
at once or something.
But we're generalizing
that as well.
Are there questions?
OK.
I have one more proof
I want to cover.
And this is the other Giovanni
paper, and Fun with Algorithms
is here.
And it's about Lemmings.
If you haven't
played Lemmings, it's
sort of the first
real-time strategy game.
So you have these characters
which appear periodically.
Then you can click on
characters and make
them do different things.
You can make them build bridges.
You can make them
dig horizontally.
dig vertically.
And so going through that again.
Here we're making this guy
climb, and then digging down.
And then digging left.
And then digging down.
And then they can dig
left to switch directions.
And then make them
dig down again.
And then build bridge
and dig through.
This is, I think,
level two or something.
It's quite challenging.
And your goal is to get as
many lemmings as possible
to the exit.
And the way you do it is
you select the ability
you want, and then you
click on the lemming
that you want to do it on.
And otherwise, they
are walking around.
So how many people
have played Lemmings?
Yeah, this is more popular one.
If you haven't
played, you should.
It's really hard, though.
I was reading Wikipedia.
Sarah, one of your
favorite authors,
Terry Pratchett was
playing Lemmings.
He wrote a book that is
clearly inspired by Lemmings.
And then he said he
had to delete Lemmings
from his computer and override
it in order to stop playing.
It was so addictive.
There are a bunch of levels.
It's fun.
There are many free
versions as well
that have duplicated the
Lemmings physics and so
on, with new levels, and there
are level editors, and all
that good stuff.
So you might expect this
game is pretty hard.
Here we're going to
prove PSPACE-hardness.
There was the first paper
by a Graham Cormode,
which showed NP-hardness and
conjectured PSPACE-hardness.
So this was the results before.
So there are all
these abilities.
I haven't defined all of them.
I'll show you just
a few of them.
If they're unlimited,
normally you're
given a limit to
how many you have.
But even when they're unlimited
and you have arbitrary time,
the game is still in PSPACE,
because again, the state
is polynomial number of bits.
OK.
There's another thing I didn't
mention, which is hazards.
These are traps.
If your lemming
goes there, you die.
So those are also important
for some of the proofs.
And so Graham showed that if you
have diggers and a time-bound,
then you get NP
equal to time-bound,
you actually get
NP-completeness.
And you can convert that
into other abilities.
But the [INAUDIBLE] new
results are this one.
We're going to focus on this
column, which is given builders
and bashers, either unlimited
or given an exponential number
of them-- because we need to
run for exponential time--
and hazards, and
just one lemming,
the game is PSPACE-complete.
Another result in the same
paper that might interest you--
but we're no longer in the
Approximation section--
is APX-hardness for
any ability you want.
And a polynomial number
of lemmings, and time,
and hazards.
And it's based on this
weird thing about hazards
that if you have many lemmings
go through a trap at once,
then only one of them dies.
[LAUGHTER]
Because the trap
has to activate,
and it takes a certain
amount of time.
So if they're really bunched
up, then most of them
can get through.
So you can use that to reduce
the number of lemmings.
And you're trying to approximate
how many lemmings get through.
OK.
So that's fun.
But I don't have
those pictures here,
because the PSPACE-hardness
is kind of the more
impressive technical thing.
And it's already
quite complicated.
So in order to really
get this proof right,
Giovanni went through
an incredible effort
of documenting Lemming physics
at a pixel-by-pixel level,
because it is pretty
weird, especially
when you start using
the bridge building.
If you've ever
played this game, it
will stop at kind
of weird moments.
So here is the physics
of what happens.
In general, the lemming is
represented by a pin right
under its left foot.
I don't know.
Maybe that's the right foot.
And that pin should
always be on the ground.
If it's not on the ground,
the lemming will fall.
If it falls too far, it dies.
But that's not relevant here.
So the general walking-- all
lemmings start as walkers.
And what they do is
basically move left to right.
There's an animation.
But mostly, this pin
is moving one pixel
to the right at a time.
And so it's visiting
these things.
Once it sees, oh, there's no
longer an obstacle beneath me,
I'm going to fall
this amount, and then
I will fall one pixel at a
time until I hit the ground.
So there's a gap here.
That won't be important here,
but this is the real physics.
If I hit a step-- and this is,
at most, eight pixels up-- then
I will rise up and go over.
But if I have two big a
step, more than eight pixels,
then when I hit the wall,
I will switch directions.
So in this case, he will hit
here and then climb back up.
That is the regular
walker physics.
Now, we're going to
use two abilities.
One is called basher.
And there's some animations here
of what happens with bashers.
In general, it's
horizontal digging.
But it's kind of weird
There's this particular
pattern that you dig,
which ends up tunneling a
big horizontal rectangle more
or less.
But the way it tells
whether it's finished
is it looks at
these four positions
right in front of the dig mask.
And if at least one of them is
solid, you will keep digging.
If they're all empty,
you will stop digging.
That's important,
because we need
to see exactly when these
things stop happening.
Then you return
to being a walker.
So if everything is normal,
you just dig through.
Here, that position was
when all four were empty.
One was empty, but then
all four were empty.
And so then you stop
digging and keep walking.
OK.
But there's also
this notion of steel.
Any pixel can be
marked as steel.
It's a separate,
independent bit.
Usually there's some graphics
to indicate your steel.
But here we're
going to use blue.
And there's this
one steel check.
And if that position
is steel, you
will immediately stop digging.
Or you will stop
digging when that start
position hits a steel pixel.
So we're going to use
that in the proof.
But that's how bashers work.
Next we have builders.
These are building
the staircases.
And there's this subtlety
that the solidity check
are these three points.
If any of them is solid,
it will stop digging.
And if this one's solid,
you'll also switch directions.
There's also a limited
number of stairs,
because you can only fit
so many in this little bag.
[LAUGHTER]
That won't matter for the proof.
We're always going
to stop before we
hit the 15 stairs or so, 10
stairs, something like that.
So you can see it
in action here.
You place the step.
The initial step overlaps
your feet by two pixels.
And then you do this offset
of two to the right, one up
until you hit
something like that.
And then in that
case, you turn around,
because you hit the
wall, so to speak.
But notice there's
this big gap here.
OK.
So now we want to
use metatheorem five.
We want to build a door
and crossover, I guess.
I don't know if I have the--
I do have the crossover here.
It's not so hard.
First we just need to be
able to move lemmings around.
And they move in
a very simple way.
So yeah.
AUDIENCE: How did he check
all these pixel things?
PROFESSOR: [LAUGHS]
That's a good question.
Definitely one
thing he did is look
at one of the clones of lemmings
and read the source code.
How that clone was done to mimic
exactly the original lemmings
I'm not sure.
So I don't know
whether this has been
compared against disassembled,
original Lemmings code or what.
I'll follow up with him.
I was talking to
him earlier today.
OK.
So we are only going to
give the player the ability
to do builders or bashers.
And we want to prevent the
player from doing builders
in random places.
So these red things are traps.
If you ever at any point
decide to become a builder,
your dot will not be here.
Your dot will be above.
And then it will be touching
the trap, and then you die.
So these red things
are to prevent you
from building anywhere.
You also can't bash
anywhere, because let's say
this is all steel.
OK.
Or actually, I think the
whole background here
is steel except in specific
places in the gadget.
So this is a small thing.
This basically let's
us ascend slightly.
Because lemmings only
like to go left and right
and there's no jump
ability, we want
to be able to build a graph.
So this will let us
go up a little bit.
This will let us go
down a little bit.
This will let us change
directions into going up,
change directions in going down.
This is a crossover,
because lemmings will just
proceed to the right.
There's no way to make
them change direction
unless they hit something.
So that's basic lemming driving.
These are not explicitly
stated in the metatheorem.
You see here the vagueness
of the metatheorem.
We need the ability
for the player
to choose whether lemmings
go one way or another way.
We need that, for example, in
the existential quantifier.
But in general, we
were kind of assuming
that the player has this kind
of agency to choose directions
of lemmings.
So for that, we need
a kind of fork gadget.
And you can either do a build
immediately followed by a bash,
or you can do a bash
in order to get down.
So if I do a build
and then a bash,
I will stop building and
then just make one step.
Because if I made a second step,
I would die from the traps.
That will let me choose
to go to the top path.
Or even if this is already
there, I could bash it away.
Or if it isn't there, just wait.
And then I will go down here.
OK?
So no matter what the
state of this gadget is,
I can either take the top path
or go down to the bottom path.
Because here I have
unlimited bashes and builds.
So those are the two states.
This is the non-steel part.
We need that for
the bash to succeed.
So it ends up bashing, but
because it's all empty here,
you immediately stop bashing.
OK.
That's the fork.
And finally, the door.
So if the door was
open, you go through it.
If it's closed, you die, even
if you try to build a bridge.
If I go this way, I
can either fall down,
or I could bash it away
and then open the door.
But I still fall to the bottom.
If I come from here with a
closed door, fine, I can exit.
If it's an open door, I
better build this thing.
If I build too far,
I'm in trouble.
But if I build just once
and then immediately bash,
then I will get to the right.
What did I just
do in rapid fire?
That was the closed path,
where I must put this
back in in order to survive.
The open, I had a choice.
I could bash it.
In either case, I end
up to the open exit.
And for traversal, you will only
survive if this is not there.
And you get out.
So lots of crossing paths.
But you can see why you need
this pixel-by-pixel analysis
to really be sure that this
gadget does exactly what you
want.
And that is a door for Lemmings.
And therefore, Lemmings
is PSPACE-complete.
Pretty epic.
And that's all for today.
Yay, video games.